[Applause]
there's a lot of pressure on us with
overwatch League to get it right
there's a lot of eyes and we're very
excited and we don't want to let people
down I think of it less in terms of we
have something to prove and more of what
I hope our legacy is both as overwatch
the game and overwatch League
esports have a vibrant and chaotic
history in 1980 Billy Mitchell became a
celebrity for his mastery of arcade
games such as pac-man and Donkey Kong
and people across the world followed
suit trying to land their names in the
Guinness Book of World Records and with
the increasing connectivity of the 1990s
online video games became a pillar of
internet culture as we transition into
the 21st century internet cafes boomed
in Asia following the 97 financial
crisis as broadband internet spread
along with high unemployment rates in
South Korea especially multiplayer games
became a staple of everyday life
teenagers across the country grew up
with dreams of becoming an eSports
legend today thousands gathered to watch
fighting games realtime strategy battles
and MOBAs in arenas across the world
tournaments such as Evo and the
International garner prize pools worth
millions of dollars
they draw mainstream attention and
celebrities alike but despite its rapid
spread the realm of eSports at least in
the grand scheme of things has remained
a relatively small community its
viewership and cultural impact are
dwarfed by those of traditional sports
if you're not what many might consider a
dedicated eSports fan you're probably
not going far out of your way to seek
out these events but today Blizzard
Entertainment one of videogames most
renowned companies is trying to change
that and that bring us here to the
blizzard Arena in Burbank California
where some of the world's best overwatch
players are facing off in the overwatch
leave for the very first time point B
right now now it's just a response dak
does go down really quick before you can
get anything with that Percy sleepy on
his own on the outside
and that's gonna be la vallee at getting
there - boy you spent a week here
getting a sense of how the whole
operation works
we interviewed players from Korea France
China Sweden and America we spoke to the
owners and managers of the individual
teams and of course we also spoke with
people from Blizzard not only about how
they began the overwatch league but what
factors will set it apart from other
esports endeavors I think we can all
remember when or have that friend if
it's not us personally where they they
weren't into a particular sport but for
whatever reason their home team makes it
to the finals and now they're gonna get
into it and becomes this lifelong love
that you suddenly have and that really
has been hard in eSports yeah we really
wanted to build that tradition that
consistency that's that structure that
you see in traditional sports and you
know if you there's millions of people
in United States right now who don't
care about football but they know that
the playoffs are going on it's at that
time of year right there and I think
that's we wanted to bring that to
eSports like we want to have make it
really easy to be a fan like really
build a consistent schedule one thing
that will happen with eSports for
example is you'll approach a game that
you're really into for the first time
and you might become aware of the
eSports scene and it's so hard to have
an immediate grasp on who you should be
associating with in any way there's all
of these organizations where if you're
an eSports fan and have been following
it for a long time they really mean
something to you and you know what these
names are and what they stand for but if
you haven't been following eSports it's
a little bit foreign in that regard so
we think bringing a regional base
approach will help some fans immediately
associate we're just here in Burbank
before we actually move to our geo
locations so for right now it's not like
you know it's sort of it's sort of
distant and for right now because we're
still stuck all in the same facility but
we're definitely looking forward to
going to like the geolocation city we
think it'll change a lot how like fans
interact with different teams you know
making a lot it's a lot easier to cheer
for someone that lives in your town than
it is for someone that's like halfway
across the grow a little bit
never even met or seen before having
franchise teams is so that you you know
sort of sort of if you decide you want
to be a fan of the LA valiant and you
don't even have to worry about them not
being in the league in another year and
so that consistency that stability
really allowed us to attract a lot of
world-class owners to come and be a part
of this and be partners with us in
building this I've always been a huge
pro sports fan and I've always loved
eSports and the two have always felt so
separate to me and there are awesome
things that pro sports does and it is
doing that we've always wish we'd seem
more of any sports and there's awesome
things about eSports that Pro Sports
doesn't understand and I'm really hoping
that this becomes the marriage and the
inspiration for eSports in general that
we could sort of level up to that that
next level and just you know really
solidify and professionalize eSports but
the more time we spent at the Blizzard
Arena talking to the owners players and
Blizzard employees the more it became
obvious just how much of a gamble the
overwatch League really is look no
further than the money it's taking to
get the league off the ground the buy-in
for just having a team here is twenty
million dollars the minimum required
salary for each player is fifty thousand
dollars and that's not including some of
the better players who have negotiated
salaries of at least 150 thousand
furthermore the Titan broadcasting site
twitch has paid ninety million to have
exclusive streaming rights over most of
the league's first two seasons then look
at the people involved there's Robert
Kraft the New England Patriots owner who
bought the Boston uprising to supplement
his sports Empire Geoff Wilpon the CEO
of the New York Mets owns the New York
Excelsior the Kroenke brothers
billionaires known for their ownership
of the Arsenal Football Club and the Los
Angeles Rams bought the LA gladiators
the oil magnate Kenneth Hirsch invested
thirty five million dollars to acquire
the Dallas fuel among other investors
are Shaquille O'Neal and Marshawn Lynch
renowned athletes in their own right
even Comcast owns an overwatch team
Comcast isn't a person but I'm sure
you've heard of it none of this
mentioned the marketing money put
forward by Activision Blizzard itself
CEO Bobby Kotick has been pushing for
the league from the beginning and at
vision's pockets are famously deep we
took a tour behind the scenes of the
blizzard arena itself once the set of
The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson and
Jay Leno it's now full of overwatch
producers casters technicians graphic
designers directors camera operators and
in-game observers there are easily
hundreds of people involved with the
overwatch lead production process as
with most major investments overwatch
league has a lot of ground to cover
before it's worth the money it's also in
a state of flux as managers and owners
figure out exactly how to run an
overwatch team roster sizes range from
the base six to the maximum twelve some
players have shared housing while other
teams believe in a more independent
approach and when asked about the
absence of any female players in the
lead despite the fact that people such
as Kim Geiger e se on are among the best
professionals in the world many managers
didn't have concrete responses they
mentioned the challenges of a female
player adapting to a male-dominated
league but didn't really seem in a rush
to find any solution some also cited the
language barrier as an obstacle however
this is a major problem for male players
as well in order to be able to reach out
to local fan bases in cities across the
world the league has made English its
default language this means all Korean
teams such as the London Spitfire and
the New York Excelsior will need to
spend hours each week learning a new
language those are valuable hours they
could spend practicing overwatch itself
all of the questions hanging in the air
about overwatch league's development
stem from the fact that Blizzard and its
partners are trying to completely evolve
a sport in a matter of months this
process took decades with football and
basketball and even longer with baseball
over watches participants are
experimenting on the fly you know you
have this monthly tournament or you have
this tournament like Korea or China or
we have Elia yo there are small term
it's that not met not small they're
actually a huge tournaments but they're
small in duration like you're training
for this one specific moment and that's
you know a weekend tournament but now
it's hey you're providing compound a
week to week basis this is not this is
not you know
a huge sprint this is like a marathon
for next six months how are you gonna
compete how are you going to improve one
of the things that we really believe in
is is the necessity of making sure that
players are healthy body and mind
outside of the game and so for us in
order to help our players just focus on
the game to the extent that they should
be it was really important for us to
have kind of an external resource to
look after their mental health right
this is a very stressful environment
they're competing against some of the
best players in the world every week
with tens of thousands of people
watching them that's not an easy
adjustment for an 18 year old kid who's
never lived away from home before we
have eight countries represented on our
team and so that that's never easy right
you know affect our play for South Korea
is still learning English and getting
accustomed to those English speaking
ability there are always these
communication issues you know when you
when you have players from many
different countries on one team and I
think that has been a challenge for us
that other teams like you know the full
Korean rosters don't have that issue
right it's never seamless right two of
our players soon and unko went from
being on an all French roster to being
on a mixed roster right we have three
players from South Korea that didn't
have amazing English skills before they
came here and those players with a wide
variety of backgrounds and a wide
variety of cultures they kind of got
here and because they were so young I
think maybe they found it easier to mesh
together than if they had been more
experienced players who had been a
little more entrenched in their habits
and in their prior conditions a good
deal communica you come to the very
important the Buddha's panel Harmon
completing some divine pool in there the
Hunger Games house of God Muhammad SAW
Kidada is a play on a most unfortunate
watch our episode it's the bunny pinky
do you know real check out you were a
grown woman and the illusion of war you
seem to keep an eye on her waters oh my
god did you see
let's do yoga I was 20 hey you've got to
go to house pond a habit and a secret
always but still despite the uncertainty
surrounding the overwatch league's
opening weeks there is a contagious
energy during its opening week overwatch
league hit 415,000 peak concurrent
viewers on Twitch with the league's
introduction to the eSports world 1943
teams signed up for the game's open
division which could potentially lead
them to a semi-professional level there
are definitely questions still hanging
in the air like will blizzard and its
partners make enough money to keep the
lead going indefinitely or will managers
find the best way to build a team or
when will we bring in some of the
world's best female players regardless
it's not every day we get to see the
birth of a sport everyone involved is
adapting on-the-fly experimenting and it
is without a doubt a massive gamble for
all involved time will tell if all of
this will eventually be enough but as of
right now everyone involved is working
to help it thrive every rivalry every
fan experience is built out of a story
out of a narrative and out of a history
right and right now overwatch League
doesn't have that much history we have a
preseason to go on but not much else and
so I'm really excited to see the way
that the overwatch League story develops
as we get through the first season of
overwatch League I think we all know
that there are certain parts of the
world such as Korea California that
everybody knows what eSports is
everybody's really into it and following
it but there's so many parts of the
world where these sports hasn't really
penetrated fully yet and it would be
great to start to see you know through
the regional based teams to get more and
more exposure to some of those parts of
the world you a Joan Boyce is your face
Honduran coaches who see your face on
daughters and that went to a woman she
wants and won't send Rio Dhabi along
today to see Jana Jose Oquendo Sandoval
go home and you certainly aren't parties
here Kwang soo to Hawaii determines this
is unclear
Holloway thought old man that song song
you know he said I don't need to
contaminate this TV it's actually not
even just the first eSport league it's
the first sport there's no sports league
in the world where Shanghai plays New
York in the regular season and I think
that's really special it's a tremendous
opportunity to bring live eSports
content to more fans around the world
you have an opportunity for Rush fans
that connect with other fans and have
that shared experience around the the
competitive matches so that that's
really the the vision is that we we get
to a point in the future where it's you
know 24 28 teams around the world
distributed across North America Europe
and Asia and just action constant action
around the world at all times we have
this whole cadre of amazing pro players
that I feel like have really been
legitimized
in their career legitimized in their
talent and their skill and they're gonna
get the recognition that they deserve
and I feel like under the overwatch
league structure they're very protected
as professionals and that's very
exciting to me these players are at an
awesome point in their lives and I think
this is amazing opportunity for them and
to me more than anything this league
centers around them and this opportunity
so that's gonna be exciting and I hope
they get the spotlight that they deserve
because they've earned it obviously the
dream is for overwatch league to become
far reaching to have people fall in love
with not only overwatch and and eSports
but our teams and our players and to
really get to know them just like any
professional sport like that would be
the ultimate goal I feel like even if we
come up short of that goal if as long as
overwatch League inspires the world that
eSports is bigger and more important
than they realize I feel like the
younger generation already gets it and
knows that this exists and that we
validate that eSports is real and
important and growing and that future
eSports endeavors strive to do something
a little bit higher a little bit better
a little bit more professional I feel
like that would be a victory the
overwatch League has lofty goals to say
the least
it also has a lot of money riding on it
and although it's impossible to say
where the whole thing will go or whether
it will reach the heights it wants to a
story has already started to form we're
only two weeks into the regular season
but rivalries have already been sparked
underdogs have proven their skill and
the team's previously thought to be
Titans have encountered their fair share
of obstacles time will tell where
overwatch League ends up but right now
it's fascinating to witness the birth of
a sport and to watch it all unfold